[peaceful music]
Wiberg: The appealing thing
of armchairs
is they always have a story.
Some of them are
100 years old,
and being able
to work with those chairs
makes my life a lot better.
In the age of 25,
I discovered that I have
this eye disease.
Now, 30 years later,
I have about
five-degree vision,
and it will decrease
until nothing's left.
Super important
that I feel the material
and feel that I'm doing
the right thing.
It's all in your hands,
and you can feel it
before you can see it.
For me, restoring chairs
is like
giving a second life
to something.
It's really a wonderful
feeling,
to make something
that really makes a difference
for other people.
[peaceful music]